he seized power in a coup and later led
the government but thailand's prime
minister is under growing pressure to
step down what if he doesn't
could that lead to further unrest
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad zhum thailand has seen
political instability since its army
chief took power in a coup eight years
ago he eventually became prime minister
but has faced resistance from many ties
who've been demanding change protesters
are now calling on praia chanocha to
resign
students at a university in northern
bangkok held protests on wednesday they
called for reforms to the monarchy and
the government's resignation authorities
have cracked down on opponents imposing
a nationwide ban on protests in 2014
but many have defied that ban in the
years since leading to hundreds of
arrests
i think the government don't really care
about the people it's like we don't
exist it feels like we're being
abandoned and left behind that's why we
have come out to voice our concerns and
hopefully push for a new government that
really cares about its people
i think change is inevitable as the
country moves forward we must rely on
our younger generation
these young people are smart i've seen
them since the beginning of the movement
i think the movement has been very
successful people have been talking
about things that have been taboo for
decades issues that were swept under the
rug it's no longer a personal struggle
but it's the people's agenda we have
raised the ceiling
as we mentioned
led a coup in 2014 that overthrew a
democratically elected government
he then served as prime minister under a
military administration until elections
in 2019 when he was chosen to remain in
power
opposition parties said the process was
rigged
now the political party chanucha
overthrew is seeking a ruling from a
constitutional court on whether prayut's
five years as head of a military junta
should count towards his eight-year
constitutional term limit
the legal move is the latest attempt by
opposition parties to reverse what they
see as an illegitimate seizure of power
and nearly two-thirds of thai voters
appear to agree a recent poll suggests
they want prime minister prayut chanocha
to leave office this month
all right let's go ahead and bring in
our guests they're all joining us from
bangkok
jay donavanic is president of the law
faculty at the college of asian scholars
is professor and director of the
institute of security and international
studies at chulang corn university
and tsunai fasook is a senior researcher
in the asia division of human rights
watch a warm welcome to you all and
thanks so much for joining us today on
inside story titinan let me start with
you today um the ptp which is the main
opposition party uh in thailand they're
seeking a court ruling to try and in the
prime minister's term sooner they want
to see it end
by august 23rd i believe is the date
they're looking for um could you please
explain this legal strategy
and the case that they are attempting to
make in the constitutional court
well the constitution
we have an article in the constitution
of 2017.
it basically imposes a term limit on any
prime minister not to last
in the in office more than eight years
so at issue here muhammad is is you know
how do you count eight years
uh i think the the opposition party the
um the various uh
uh protagonists people who are filing
complaints and petitions uh they are
trying to count eight years from the
time that prime minister bayout
seized power and became prime minister
back in 2014
in august on august 24th 2014. so on
august 24th this year
um this would be the time that he would
have to leave office now there are
different ways of counting when he began
some people his people are saying that
you know it should be counted when the
constitution was promulgated
in july 2017 or when the election
took place in 2019 when he took office
then at that time so different ways of
counting the eight years i think that
the um you know the prime minister he's
his popularity i think he's at a low
point and and he's been around a long
time uh people want change so there's
mounting pressure
for him to to step aside to step down
for a clean slate so we have elections
and that's what we're hoping for i think
many people in thailand but
his supporters and his side is the
ruling party they want him to last all
the way to the next election which must
be called by march 2023
so now you know the constitutional court
uh is uh in the hosting because it has
to decide and remember too muhammad and
you know our viewers that the
constitutional court has been deciding
in favor of general payet
through the years so for example in 2019
in july you know his cabinet swore an
incomplete oauth of office in complete
oath of office but they got away with it
the constitutional court basically
said they had no jurisdiction even
though it had to deal with the issues of
the constitution and then there were
other cases where pretty much general
youth got his way through the
constitutional court through the
election commission through the
anti-corruption commission so there's no
reason to doubt this time that the
constitutional court will decide the
same way uh however uh public pressure
is mounting so so the judges will be uh
you know under a lot of pressure to to
be straight and impartial
uh jade um you know uh titinan just now
mentioned something that i wanted to ask
you about as well which is the fact that
there there are different
entities on the political scene in
thailand uh that are are counting how
many years the prime minister has been
in office uh differently and it gets a
little confusing uh you have some
supporters arguing that his premiership
began in 2017 uh which would mean that
he could stay in power until 2025 you
have others who say that it began after
the 2019 election which which means he
should be able to stay in power in
theory until 2027 from your vantage
point who is right
well actually uh uh taking from kitty
nan
fisa 29 was pointing out that there was
an article under the constitution which
is article 158
that terms the prime minister no more
than eight years
then there's another article 264
which said that the cabinet in office
prior to the coming into force of the
constitution
the cabinet prior to the constitution is
the cabinet under the constitution that
means that the cabinet has been a
cabinet ever since prior to
the effective date of the constitution
it's also the cabinet
under the constitution of 2017.
so who is within the cabinet it is the
prime minister which is general baruch
as well as the other ministers
so counting general purdue it has to be
counted from 24th august
2014
on all the way until this year august
the 23rd then that is the the correct
term as i see
counting towards uh
the the terms under article 158 as well
as linking to
article 264.
many people were counting that it starts
2017 because they said that the
constitution came into force
6 april 2017 therefore it has to be
counted on that day
but many others counted after election
when
he was appointed by by his majesty the
king
around june
2019 but for me the correct
interpretation will be that you have to
bundle article 158 together with 264
therefore his term ends the night of the
23rd august of this year
tsunami does the effort to remove the
prime minister from office have a lot of
public support at this point and if he
is not removed what happens then what
happens next
well the sense of dissatisfaction
has grown significantly due to poor
performance and let's not forget that
rayon has no legitimacy from the
beginning because his stage accused that
overthrew
a democratically elected government he
has no legitimacy from the beginning and
now it is
a critical juncture which
his credential is being questioned
based on constitutional rule and this
constitution rule is actually drafted by
prague and his
uh cronies
so it is his you know his foundation is
kind of crumbling
upon his own doing so
already that you know
this week there was a resumption of
political rally in bangkok in the the
outskirts of bangkok a university
and and and and
there seemed to be assumption already
among pro democracy activities uh that
they are hoping
there will be a quick end to reduce term
as titinan and jay just said that you
know uh it could come in less than a
week from now if his term
come to an end on the 23rd of august
this is very soon and now democracy
groups are not calling for
a new street protest what they are
calling for is a free and fair election
that will lead to landslide victory of
pro-democracy political parties and that
would lead to
a genuine
kind of transition of thailand back to
democracy undoing the legacy of military
hunter undoing the current
constitutional framework undoing all
those institution institutions that have
protected you from accountability so
this seemed to be the
the game plan of pro-democracy movements
in thailand at the moment uh titinan
jade just mentioned that there were some
protests that happened in the past a few
days um and you know there have been
many youth-led protests against the
prime minister um do you think that
we're going to see more going forward
i think yes we will definitely see more
going forward i mean if going forward
means in the months and years ahead uh
the reason we have protests and will
continue to have protests is because
people are unhappy people are unhappy
because the political system is unjust
unfair and and partial to the one side
you know basically i mean this this uh
controversy and crisis for peru on this
uh eight eight year term limit is ironic
uh muhammad because you know this this
provision was written not against him
not it was not meant for him it was
meant for his um exiled nemesis uh
someone like taksin shinowat who's
living abroad
is is meant to prevent
any individual from dominating electoral
politics in thailand but now the
constitution the law in thailand now is
about power it's not about fairness and
justice it's about who has the power and
who holds the power and how to keep
power so i would not be surprised if the
constitutional court somehow decides
again in general produce favor despite
um you know jade and dr jason and mr
sunai's comments that he lacks
legitimacy that this is a violation of
the constitution because the various
dynamics
and the powers that be i think are still
behind
so that's why we're gonna see more
protests because people see it
especially younger people because you
know they look at their future and it's
been it's been taken hostage by the
youth-led regime and they want to do
something about it we saw that two years
ago and we'll see more of it
jade if anger continues to build and and
if the prime minister doesn't either
step down or or if the constitutional
court rules in his favor that he can
continue to serve um from your vantage
point does that mean that we're looking
at the possibility of widespread
instability or turmoil
yes and and you see the uh now the
demonstrators are not only calling on
you to resign they are calling in in
three prongs they are calling for
constitutional amendment secondly
they're calling general purdue to resign
and thirdly which is
which is not quite stable for the
country and i think that may cause a
torment again because they are calling
for reform with a monarchy
those two other things the
constitutional amendment and reform of
monarchy doesn't have anything to do
with general pre-signing or not but
because general peru is not dealing with
anything that would be fair and would be
seen from the liberal point of view as
making something impartial and making
something uh fair and equitable so so
now he's dragging on on and on and then
the constitution will be hurt and as
well as the monarchy so i think you may
see
that things will get worse and worse
and afterwards if
they stay on you still have another
issue about the electro system that they
are trying to drag the electrical system
to the parliament system and then
to
the proportional system then now back to
the parliament system so no one knows
what really happens now and what they
really want and people were saying that
some parties are making an agreement
that okay general purdue can stay on but
they want the parliament system because
when they head on to the campaign into
the election they will win drastically
they will win landslides so who knows
what happened now
everything will be in chaonte
tsunai i want to ask you about
another aspect of what's going on in
thailand right now just take a step back
for a moment in its 2022 world report
human rights watch said the thai
government further repressed basic
rights and crackdown on the youth-led
democracy movement in 2021. uh what is
the overall situation in thailand right
now when it comes to human rights
well let's not forget that thailand is
still under emergency decree enforced by
general peru
and this emergency degree can be
activated
to the extent that all excess all form
of the exercise of fundamental freedom
freedom expression assembly association
can be totally banned and discrimination
information such as you know report by
mary watch can also be banned and
punished as false information or
disinformation so he has a very potent
tool
which is draconian in nature in his hand
already and he has been using that
that's explained why we have
hundreds and hundreds of of us behind
bars are being charged for
uh expressing that their opinions uh
that descending voice against the
government as as they just said that
they had three demands not only those
three demands about produce resignation
in new constitution and reform of monagi
not only these three demands have not
been met or responded
they are being punished
for making such demands
so this is the the situation of
overall kind of human rights landscape
that thailand has become a draconian
repressive society under general
prejudice rule and how long
can people put up with this my answer is
people are not going to tolerate this
anymore that explains why they risk
their lives to take to the street there
is their future
and there's nothing to lose anymore uh
jared and he did not talk about these
youngsters seeing that it is a fight for
the better future to reclaim their
rights to determine their own future
this is why the risk being put behind
bar there is being beaten up by police
being shot at by police or office
charges that can keep them behind bar
for decade this is the risk that these
youngsters are taking
and they see that if now they are
pinning the hope that graduate will be
forced out of the office there will be a
new election
if the expectations are not met
who knows what will happen next
titinan you mentioned uh in your answer
a few moments ago uh you talked a little
bit about former prime minister thaksin
and uh and i wanted to to ask you a
little bit about that because you you
wrote a piece entitled keeping
democratic institutions weak uh in which
you you wrote a bit about what had
happened to the former prime minister
and and one of the things you said in
this piece was the worst thing one can
do in thai politics is to run for office
and win by a landslide i just wanted to
to get your perspective on what exactly
that means what did you mean when you
wrote that
apparently the locus of power the way
that power works and its exercise in
thailand
is not through
popular mandate fundamentally so you can
have elections you know we've had uh as
you know two military coups over the
past two decades and three constitutions
over the last 25 years
we've had uh dissolutions of major big
political parties imagine in any country
that the major political parties are
dissolved left and right and time and
again so basically this is a way of
keeping
democratic institutions in parliament
political parties elected
representatives keeping them weak by
dissolving the parties by banning
politicians and you know doing so allows
the traditional institutions of the
military the bureaucracy the judiciary
the monarchy to be strong so basically
it is not possible so far in thailand to
have strong democratic institutions
because traditional institutions will
raise we assert themselves and we've
seen this time and again over the last
25 years
and we'll probably see some more of it
but there's a kind of a reckoning that i
think is coming along because uh new
demographics younger generations they
they don't want to put up with this
anymore and you know we've gone past the
cold war we've had the change of the
monarch to the new monarch the previous
monarch lasted for for seven decades so
now i think it's kind of a new thailand
that the old power centers are unwilling
to recognize and accept and therefore we
have a lot of tension confrontation
demonstrations protests
and uh so far it's been suppressed uh
repressed but uh over time in the longer
term uh it'll be very difficult to avoid
and to prevent this kind of reckoning
from taking place afterwards we can only
hope that thailand will find some kind
of a compromise for a way forward i
think if you look if you listen to the
the message the demands of these
protesters well they they want the
reform they don't want the revolution i
mean this is a country that uh you know
it's good for compromise negotiations uh
degrees of separation very small so if
you can have some kind of reform so that
the various uh political players um the
political balance is is uh reach
in a new fashion that is satisfactory to
young people older people all kinds of
people and that's the way forward for
thailand
jade are there any indications out there
are there any signs of how the military
is viewing all that is going on
i think they're just observing what is
going on right now but they will take
action let's say after
uh the election let's say if the
election is had and then afterwards the
the liberal
got the uh the majority of the lower
house
then that majority of the lower house
might not bring them a prime minister
because you have to have also the uh the
vote from the senate
then if the conservative put together
with
the the senate
then they win the liberal part
people come on the street the
demonstrator it might be a riot and then
afterwards the military will take action
then and there may be another cool stage
um let me ask you also since you
mentioned the elections uh will the
elections actually happen uh according
to the timetable that is that is laid
out is expected they're gonna happen in
march of 2020 2023 do you think that's
going to be the case
uh it might not be in march because
march will be uh the ending of the term
of the parliament then around 60 days
after the the ending okay no more than
that or 45 days depending on whether or
not the the parliament is dissolved if
the parliament is dissolved then you
have 60 days if the parliament just ends
with the the actual terms then it will
be 45 days so march is the ending about
24 march okay so 24th march is the
ending then counting from there 45
states there will be the election and
then after that then the the chaotic
situation may be uh occurring
uh tsunami um
are you getting any indications that
that cracks are emerging in in the
ruling coalition and and do you think
that there's any chance that the prime
minister might step down
well pray youth
is
i think he is leading me into to stay on
um first of all he believed that
you know against all the facts he
believed that he is the the holder of of
national unity and stability which i
totally disagree
and he's the cause of division is the
cause of discontent
but he seems to think otherwise and and
he think that
he has to stay on the power for the sake
of the nation but people think
differently of course
and another thing
is thailand going to host the epic
meeting later this year and for bryout
it is something that he wants to leave
behind as his
personal legacy that you know
he who is not known to have
any kind of
credential in in in diplomacy in
international relations managed to be
the prime minister of thailand at the
time of epic meeting
meeting or hosting world leaders so this
is something that he wants to achieve so
he will
kind of
bang everything
on the decision of the constitutional
court which up until now has
been partial and making decisions in
produce favor all along so he's banking
his hopes
in that basket
we only have about a minute left i just
very quickly want to ask you from your
perspective do you think that elections
are going to be happening early next
year
well election is it has to happen put it
this way election will have to happen i
don't think the military will dare to
stay shaku otherwise they will face with
the fierce resistance from the thai
population we are now having
the fearless generation who have
proven they're being bold being couraged
and taken to the street over the past
three years and they will see something
much bigger if the military dare to
stage a crew or someone there to derail
the
timeline of the next election
all right well we have run out of time
so we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thanks so much to all
of our guests jay donavanic tinitan pong
su dirac and sunai pashuk
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again any time by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
muhammadan's room and the whole team
here bye for now
[Music]